three two one thank you
to those and abstentions
to you okay lovely I will sign those
afterwards right let's move to our first
planning application then which is
application
220003 ful Lander Elms Farm Newbold
Pacey our presenting officer is
shirtlesey Stuart over to you
thank you chairman good evening
this proposal is seeking temporary
planning fishing for the installation of
a solar farm together with all associate
development necessary equipment and
infrastructure the applicant is seeking
to install this solar farm for a maximum
period of 40 years
the application site is just to the west
and southwest of the village of newborn
Pacey in an area of open Countryside as
indicated by the red line on this plan
the site is the immediate west of
Newbold Road
um there is a conservation area within
the village signified by the purple
boundary uh on my cursor here
um
here we have the submitted proposed site
layout plan one can see the proposed PV
panel array divided up across five
Fields the dotted blue line and here and
the dotted red line here
signify the extent of public rights of
way and access
um
here we have the proposed elevational
detail of the proposed panels uh one can
see the extent of the panels themselves
with a maximum height to the highest
point there of 3.1 meters and uh 0.8 to
1.1 meters at the lowest point
uh here we see some imagery taken from
the applicant's design and access
statement this imagery gives a greater
idea of the appearance of the panels
that are proposed in addition to some of
the other Associated development and
equipment and infrastructure
um big button and just to the right here
um we can see here indicative imagery of
the possibility of sheep also grazing
under said panels
um here on this slide uh we see simply
some further indicative imagery taken
from the applicant's submission
we now have some slight photos of the of
the site here we are just stood off the
access track off new board road to the
north east of the sites looking South
westwards uh towards a patch of Woodland
uh here that is outside of the
application boundary and has to be
retained as part of The Proposal
here we are stood
um
in the same position looking South
Eastward toward back towards the village
here we are stood on the Northern edge
of the application boundary looking in a
Westward Direction one can see a slight
gradient change as it slopes towards the
direction of the highway
here we are now stood in the crude
center of the largest field looking back
northwards again towards a patch of
Woodland there that is to be retained
um finally we are stood here on the
green verge of newborn Road looking
Westward towards the application site
here on the right
um
wanted to see that there is some uh
hedgerowin screening currently in Citrus
um the pros are seeking to install
renewable infrastructure to deliver
stable energy to both the media and
wider area as is detailed in the agenda
pack the district council has declared a
climate change emergency this proposal
aligns precisely with this commitment as
is detailed in the agenda packs there is
to be no change of use or loss of
agricultural land furthermore as is
detailed there is found to be a
biodiversity net gain by not farming
this land for what is the maximum period
of 40 years with opportunities for
undergrazing beneath the panels having
considered all material planning
considerations inclusive of matters of
Highways impacts on landscape character
and heritage heritage assets and more
this proposal is found by officers to
record with local and National planning
policy any limited harm that has been
found is significantly outweighed by
public benefits that would be accrued
both the local and wider Community I
refer everybody to the update sheet for
updates including a member site visit
that took place this afternoon uh
chairman the recommendations to Grant
this application for the reason set out
on pages 42 and 42 44 of your agendas
thank you
Stuart thank you very much indeed let's
call our first Speaker of the evening
who is councilor Wright of Newbold Pacey
and ashwan Parish Council
good evening Council rights and welcome
thank you for your patience as we got
through our Gremlins at the start you'll
be pleased to know we can now be heard
on the live recordings
um so you'll have three minutes
um whenever you're ready if you push the
button in the middle the light will turn
red and it's over to you the floor is
yours can you hear me
oh good evening the parish council quite
rightly a support solar energy provision
but raises the strongest possible
objection to the proposal for this solar
farm
located on open undulated and actually
unsport Countryside the development wood
by its presence destroy completely the
natural character Beyond any form of
acceptability or mitigation
the parish council questions a
recommendation of grand when considered
against the policy of the council Court
strategy
the main issues being impact on
landscape and their sheer scale of the
development
of course actually these states the
countryside is appreciated as a major
asset and its protection important
policy C3 States solar energy
acceptability will be assessed against
the issues of particular local
significance namely
impact on the openness and the character
of both landscape and visual immunity
impact on the character of historic
landscape
impact of direct and reflected light
including glare on the immunity and also
occupy building occupied buildings land
and I would add Aviation at this point
impact on the use and disturbance of
agricultural land this is always cropped
the policy further States large-scale
solar proposals be determined in
accordance with sdc's landscape
sensitivity study which states and I
quote development sites should be
generally fairly small on flat land and
screened to avoid adverse effects on the
topography and the landscape pattern
to propose conflicts with this
and I wouldn't call 96 Acres small on
flat land here or indeed well screened
policy S5
specifically emphasized the importance
on assessing any harm development would
cause to landscape quality character and
visual impact on landscape features and
Woodlands
the proposed conflicts both with this
and the Warwickshire landscape
guidelines and leave the mppf that
states importance of protection to the
natural environment and valued
landscapes
policy cs7 refers to rural character of
The District its landscape protection
and distinctiveness from inappropriate
development
the proposed conflicts strongly with
this I would suggest
policy C12 again refers to the
importance to maintain and enhance the
rural character of The District 30
seconds the distinctive Countryside and
protected from inappropriate development
to conclude that Council previously
refused a solar farm on this side
for the policy reasons I've stated
they're proposed if approved would
completely destroy the Asian character
of Newbold paisy and its historic
landscape character The Proposal is
alien yes alien by its intentions and
would cause extreme demonstrable harm to
the area and I urge you to refuse the
application thank you
you can't write those spots on three
minutes thank you very much indeed if
you remain seated while we see if you
have any questions members do we have
any questions for councilor Wright
Council Mills
nice to be chairman hello Roger good to
see you again yes
um Roger you mentioned about Aviation
yes indeed
um I didn't handy consultation with the
wellsborn Airfield
um Pilots or whoever did they make any
comments on it I don't know if they were
inquired on them or not but certainly
the last application which I referred to
it was a serious issue with the CAA
because you have an issue flying that's
training flying into wellsborn and this
is his direct approach into zero two
three and so therefore you're doing a
question of particularly disturbing area
we've got the solar panels it was an
issue last time
I'm gonna stop you I think you've
answered the question but thank you very
much um we can we can refer that to our
uh case oscillator on I think you'll if
you notice in your report pack there has
been a consultation with uh Aviation but
we'll refer to that later cancer Curtis
thank you
[Music]
um
previously refused was it a lot of
divisional detail about going down
and wasn't exactly so impaired hey I'm
an image 2008 when I was on the council
at the time
um it was not as large as this nowhere
near it but certainly if you refuse for
the reasons I've given that landscape
damage and all that plus of course the
aviation question as well
thank you and it was largely in in the
same area but indeed you're on path same
area yes
new Bob Edge itself thank you
any other questions
um I have one if I may you mentioned
during your speech um a section about
small uh small scale on flat land and
you're referred to as policy document
but I didn't catch what you said the
police document was
it's your core strategy document there
was a particular section of it and it
actually that's contained with the
special
um let me refer back to it the landscape
sensitivity study that refers
particularly to flatland fairly
generally is very small a screen to
avoid adverse effects and obviously you
know it it states flat land this in fact
is not flat land at all or a very small
area it's like land okay thank you I
will again I'll ask for clarification of
the offices for that later on unless
anyone else has got any questions we'll
move on no council rights thank you very
much for your time thank you indeed
thank you
okay let's move to our next speakers of
the evening who are Mr Andrew Marshall
and Mr Daniel Simpkins
if you'd like to both make your way
forward
you can share a chair if you if you want
to but
[Laughter]
um now you do have three minutes between
you do you want are you gonna do a
minute and a half minute and a half or
do you want me to time it for a minute
and a half I'll give you 30 second
warning at a minute is that okay who's
gonna start
every 10 seconds
you're happy with that yeah okay
whenever you're ready it's over to you
this development application is all
about money income for the investors and
for the little family the energy crisis
is sdc's agenda and rightly so in this
case the two are not compatible a
willing landowner convenient group
connection and an experienced developer
do not always lead to the right site
selection
sdc's planning team have extensively
relied upon the experts paid for by
novas many of the conclusions and
recommendations referred to are based
upon our judgment and our subjective
this really suits the applicant
there are numerous inaccuracies errors
and emissions in the application from
the size of the development to the
non-existence of the country County Road
e69a2 which borders the areas two three
four and five and is on the County's
definitive map
astonishingly both coryless and the
planning team are in denial about the
Autumn 30 seconds from October to the
end of March deciduous teas and hedges
have no leaves consequently the solar
part becomes clearly visible from the
b4087 the new roll Road all of its 10
foot high black panels the mature hedge
referred to is Elm and not surprisingly
it's dying held up by the Ivy the soil
is so poor that the neighboring Farmer
and the littles have just harvested
their crops as they have done for
decades no make that centuries
whenever you're ready
if you press the button in the middle
it'll turn red we just check can I just
check that your microphone is off now it
is brilliant hello yeah yeah you give
yourself a little bit of space because
otherwise you'll get some feedback
whenever you're ready it's over to you
great thank you the application contains
too many misleading and false statements
and a decision in favor would be unsound
and open to challenge for instance the
area of the proposed solar farm is over
double the stated 18 hectares which
alone has caused people to base their
opinions on something that is only half
as big as it actually is
great play has been made by the
applicant of the independence of experts
yet we find at least one has shared
directors with novas this conflict was
confirmed by novas at the public
consultation at the same time novas
disclosed their site selection criteria
sequeling landlords close to the grid
there was only one that is why the
application has been made on undulating
high quality agricultural land planning
offices have placed too much Reliance on
the accuracy and Independence of the
information from the applicant and
officers have replicated the same weak
arguments word for word there is no
attempt by officers to separate fact
from fiction there is no taking account
of the significant robust policy-based
objections raised by significant
opposition
the applicant postulates 137 sorry 31 of
the land is bnv and that 3A land cannot
be farmed separately the officers have
asserted these misleading statements as
fact yet the same arable land is being
farmed today as it has been for hundreds
of years approving this application
based on misleading and false statements
will be unsound thank you
also spot on one minute 30. we're doing
very well here members do we have any
questions for our speakers
no
okay gentlemen thank you sorry I thought
you said no counselor Harvey
it's a nice quick enough
um it's um
it's a serious matter to make
allegations of misleading statements of
fact
it would help me if you could identify
what those are okay
sorry I I don't it's not an allegation
like all things if I'm selling something
and clearly the applicant here is
selling the concept of a solar farm and
they are using experts to to conduct
studies we found that one of the experts
had a director relationship with novas
so therefore can't be considered
independent things like the soil sample
so the soil sample the the application
sorry the applicant is stating that this
is not land that can be farmed but we
see a crop we see crops all around here
you know crops that have been cultivated
harvested and they have been for
hundreds of years so if we're looking at
the soil sample
the people who conducted the soil sample
did so for a solar application if those
same if that same company conducted a
soil sample to demonstrate that we can
grow crops you'd expect the answer to be
distorted in one way or the other that's
what I'm saying
and I'm sorry if I can just
briefly yeah I'm not suggesting that the
planning I'm suggesting that the
planning officers are relying too much
on the application
on the statements because they are not
quantitative statements that there is a
lot of subjectivity in there
understood thank you for clarifying that
if you wouldn't mind turning your
microphone off as well please thank you
members I'm do we have any other
questions
no gentlemen thank you very much for
your time contributions and patience
okay let's move to our next speakers who
are um Simon now I apologize if I get
your surname ROM is it damaged marvelous
timing damage and we have Stephen Nori
as well if you want to both make your
way up to the desks in front of us
now between you you've got six minutes
uh how are you wanting to split your
time
okay so I'll uh give you 30 second
warning for three minutes is up and then
I'll let you know when three minutes is
up whenever you're ready over to you
thank you chair uh my name is Simon
Gammage and I'm head of planning with
Novus the applicant I'm here to ask
members to support your officer's
recommendation for approval for our
solar farm and I fully endorse the
balance assessment of potential effects
and benefits of The Proposal in their
report
we've been active in the development of
solar projects since 2010 and we're
passionate about tackling the climate
emergency
following the hottest day on record in
the UK then the Mexican energy crisis we
have just come out of the second heat
wave of the summer
and we've all seen the threat of
blackouts
we've experienced the driest July since
1935 begins to Drought being declared in
parts of England
the urgency of the climate situation is
impossible to ignore then Collective
action must be taken
this proposes part of that solution to
those issues
we've carefully selected this site
it's located outside any areas
designated to the landscape and ecology
status
it's not at a risk of flooding and the
majority of the site is in lower grade
agricultural land
importantly the location also has an
efficient connection to the local grid
Network where there's capacity in the
road adjacent to the site as members
will know that's a very important part
of the success of these projects we
depend upon having good grid connections
I'd like to highlight the following
benefits of the proposals if I may
the solar farm would help deliver the
council in UK government's renewable
energy targets and Net Zero strategy
it would increase the current supply of
electricity's Renewables in the district
by 25 percent
it would power over five and a half
thousand homes which is about nine
percent of all homes in the district
across the site we deliver a 90
biodiversity net gain this includes a 10
meter deep planting battle on Woodland
Road and Wildflower and grassland grass
seeding across the site
as your officer mentioned we'd also
provide for Agricultural co-use and she
would be allowed to continue to graze
the sites at near normal stocking
densities and after 40 years the site
will be fully decommissioned and all
equipment removed from site and recycled
I'd also like to say with regards to
scale this is the joint's smallest solar
site proposal in the district since 2014
at 25 megawatts it's the same as the
approved Eastlands Farm projects in
harboring which is recently approved and
just for context our proposals use about
40 less land than that project we've
designed this very efficiently
we're conscious our proposal generated a
lot of interest but amongst that is a
lot of support about 60 of
representations later in support of the
project 30 seconds
there are no objections from especially
statutory consultees we've listened to
feedback we've received and we've
created additional work and tailored our
proposals in response to that feedback
to conclude our application presents a
real opportunity to significantly reduce
carbon emissions and to help tackle
climate change the impacts of which
we're all feeling more than ever
thank you for your time and I hope you
feel able to support your office's
recommendations for approval this
afternoon
mamas thank you very much and you've
given Mr Nori an extra 10 seconds a
scenario whenever you're ready I'll give
you a 30 second warning before your time
is up it's over to you
I'm here as the chair of Stratford
climate action facing the climate
emergency time is off the essence
according to the ipcc we have just over
seven years to reduce Global emissions
by 43 percent developed countries need
to decarbonize sooner according to a
report prepared for the council by
anthesis to meet Paris Target Stratford
would need a 13.9 annual reduction in
greenhouse gases between 2005 and 2017
the annual reduction was only 1.7 with
business as usual we'd only see a total
16 reduction by 2030.
Stratford's current targets would
achieve a 53 reduction by 2030. how are
we doing on this according to anthesis
by 2030 we need deep retro fitting of 17
000 houses 47 of domestic heating
systems to be low carbon or electric 24
increase in Forest coverage and so on at
present I can't see that that is really
happening
as to renewable energy we need an
additional 124 megawatts capacity of
local onshore wind which also isn't
happening and 69 megawatts of solar it's
only this surprisingly modest solar
Target that we seem to be moving on with
the necessary speed
Council figures working on climate
change have told me they're looking to
over achieve the solar targets to
compensate for under achievement
elsewhere but that'll only happen if
proposals such as this are passed I
don't think it's responsible to block
solar projects that are actually on the
table because we're waiting for
government to maybe make it easier to
install solar panels on roofs or for
perfect sites to come forward that no
one will object to
we surely all have a deep investment in
the future of the countryside but we
shouldn't let rhetoric run away with us
Talk of the industrialization of the
countryside in Vegas invokes images of
dark satanic Mills pumping out poisonous
smog when what we're facing is quiet
clean solar panels surrounded by
Wildflower Meadows nibbled by a few
sheep and largely screened from view by
hedgerows and tree planting
in fact Fields like these are already
industrialized for much of the year the
soil is left bare degrading ecology
fertility and appearance at other times
they're covered by industrial monocrops
grown with fertilizers that release
greenhouse gases and run into our rivers
to feed algae blooms
they're protected by pesticides that are
crashing insect levels turning Fields
into ecological deserts
fields of maize which may be for
biofuels not food may look nice under
the Summer sun but that's no measure of
the health of the countryside
this project would boost biodiversity
and let the soil recover in 30 seconds
perhaps you're worried about food
production in light of recent price
Rises and droughts that's only going to
get worse the hotter it gets clearly we
need government to move us to a more
sustainable and resilient agricultural
future for instance moving land away
from biofuels and animal agriculture but
waiting for that shouldn't be an excuse
for inaction on the climate emergency if
the existence of more than one crisis is
used as an excuse for maintaining
business as usual we're clearly all
doomed our opinion is that solar
developments such as this are part of
the response to the multifaceted crisis
we face and preserving the status quo is
not thank you
thank you very much both of you if we
could stay seated for questions members
do we have any questions for either of
our speakers
cancer Crump
good afternoon gentlemen um
the previous speaker spoke about some
potential inaccuracies
um particularly around I think soil
sample was mentioned and also about the
size of the the site just like some
feedback on that as a sense of balance
no thank you
um in terms of the site area we deferred
to the red line submitted with the plan
application as reported in in the office
of report so if there's any
misunderstanding about that I'd hope
it's been cleared by this point in the
application process
um
I don't really have a lot more to add
than that other than we've declared it
fakely on the application forms and
it is Duty submitted if I may am I able
to offer a clarifying comment thank you
chairman um just yes speaking to uh the
applicant's comment there um it would
appear there was something of a should
we say clerical error on the application
form
um in other in the planning statement
the site hectare area is all stated
correctly and all the supporting uh
documents including the agricultural
land classification others the
consistent figure of 39 hectares is
quoted I take the application form where
there is an error to be a clerical error
this application has been fully assessed
on the basis that the site is indeed 39
hectares so I'm comfortable from an
office point of view this has been
assessed correctly
okay thank you very much Council flaming
um normally under circumstances these
these schemes
um give some pay back to the local
people that are mostly affected by this
um what's in it for the local people
that are going to have to have this
this system installed in the land
surrounding their homes what what's
actually in it for them
thank you
um
so entirely separate to the planning
process because it's not it can't be
material in decision making which is why
I've not mentioned it and the officers
not mentioned it we will put in place a
community benefit fund if that's the
sort of theme we're touching on
um that would usually be payable to the
local community we do that for all of
our projects
um irrespective of support for anyone's
position locally at a standardized rate
so if we were successful in gaining
planning consent one of our first
actions would be to agree with the local
Parish how to administer that fund
um in terms of values that would be uh
we would usually administer an annual
payment based on the size of the product
that'd be a little over six thousand
pounds a year or about a quarter of a
million pounds across the life of the
project
I just want to clarify is that something
that we are
um you are signing up to through a legal
agreement with the council so through an
s106
so no 106 attached we would do it uh
through an agreement directly with the
parish so no one who sits proposed as
part of the application
foreign
the legal advice I'm getting here is is
whilst that is a very helpful and useful
thing for the applicant to do it's not
specific to this application it's
outside of the application scope so it's
not part of our decision making just so
we're clear
exactly
members do we have any other questions
Council of Rock
thank you chairman uh they're going to
address a a point the second speaker
made about
um mono culture sort of crops
uh just want to clarify that was
presumably a general statement you were
making about fields that may or may not
be replaced by solar farms in general
rather than this specific site because
some of us have worked Acro walked
across those fields this afternoon I can
tell you they weren't minor crops
because there's beans in one and we
stumbled in another can I just clarify
you you weren't a legend it was a mono
crop this year in those fields
because that would be inaccurate
I was talking about monoculture so if
it's you know just one crop in one part
and one crop another it can still be
farmed as a monocrop in those two
different parts
um I have not walked over the field but
um industrial agriculture would
generally be considered a monoculture
um in that sense
cancer Curtis
thank you yes I was about to ask a
similar Point
um you mentioned uh sorry Mr Gammage
um the 90
biodiversity net gain
um how have you got examples of previous
sites that you've developed where you
can demonstrate that and how would that
how would that be measured and over what
sort of period would you expect that to
be achieved
so um
the body's Net game concept is
relatively new in terms of the
requirement environment act deliver 10
net gain is is relatively mature that
was about 18 months ago that came in so
the requirement to monitor against the
target uh is a fairly New Concept so for
weather sites uh where we have
um predicted and committed to delivering
similar amounts we will unilaterally
monitor that so we will go out annually
and we will check progress of the
implemented measures and we'll report
back on that in some cases we've had a
condition requiring us to do that I
don't think one's proposed in this case
but but we've there are examples of that
being controlled by planning condition
as well
and would you
um welcome independent monitoring of
that as well yeah absolutely we're keen
to do that as transparently as possible
thank you
cancer hence your seraphin thank you
no
wooden sheep grazing under panels
contribute more to greenhouse gas than
using it as agricultural land
I would say they do produce a lot of
greenhouse gas I'm not sure of whether
sheep are planned for this or not but I
would assume that if they were there
would be a minor a small amount but okay
thank you
any other questions members
cancer Mills thanks very much um I
read somewhere about the rewilding
would that take place under the panels
as well
and uh yes so so beneath panels around
the Primitive sites and there's a an
ecological area in the southwest corner
of the site as well so all across the
site so something will grow under the
panels without any light or without any
water or yep so so the Arab municipants
is not is not devoid of light it will
get lighter to various points during the
normal day and our experiences is um
grass species makes his world grow and
the panels quite happily it's because
rewilding is better on uh
on poor land actually and this is not
and we this is
I know we're probably going over these
people is this poor agricultural land so
in in terms of Agriculture what grade is
it so so the size broadly 70 grade free
being 30 grade 3A so grade 3B is not
best and most versatile land in grade
three eight is so it's predominantly not
best of myself so all the land around
there is of the same grade
there's a split so broadly two-thirds
grade freebie one third grade freea
foreign
scheme if I may and our office is just
bringing it up now so I'm just so I'm
clear of what's going around the site
and within the site there's the um
you're putting some a new Woodland in on
this picture it's the sort of top right
field on that boundary
and then to the field left of the green
wooded area you're putting something
there are they going to be evergreen
trees are they going to be quite thick
and bushy all year round and similarly
through the hedges are you replanting
all the hedges or just in gaps where
there are gaps and again what are you
putting in are they going to be all year
round Bush type structures
so in answer your question I would need
to check whether species are ever in or
not but that would be controllable
through planning conditions so we you
know there is ample opportunity to to
manage those species mixes
the sites uh is already there's already
benefits from a good amount of screening
so our objective theory is to Gap up and
reinforce and enhance what's there
already so we're proposing planting at
various points around the site in order
to do that um is your question whether
we'll plant in every inch of the
boundary I'm assuming you're not
planting in every inch of the boundary
I'm basing on what I'm seeing here the
thick green areas are going to be
roughly where you're going to be
planting yes yes yeah yeah that's
helpful thank you
cancer cramp
just for not sorry for a second question
coming back
um again the previous speakers mentioned
that some of the hedgerows were Alm and
obviously Elm hasn't been doing very
well in this country the last 50 years
since
Dutch helmet Etc
um and it was only held together by Ivy
or it appeared to be hard to get the
biology so which is which is not really
not very strong and not particularly
good for the environment either so again
it it's just an assessment of that
Landscaping yes you've mentioned
conditions but we you know would like to
make sure that
those Hedges that seem first glancing
you cancer crumb can you get to your
question please
that's it was it Magnus used to say I've
started so I'll finish
um it was just yeah it's just the fact
that we need to make sure that any
conditions of the Landscaping is looked
up properly because of you know it looks
green because the IV but underneath it's
it's dead or down because it's it's our
I fully understand the question
absolutely councilor Crump
um I don't know the answer to how many
albums are in in the borders in the
boundaries of the sites
um
clearly as part of the Landscape
Management plan we would have accounts
of that
um I I don't believe it's the majority
of trees that are affected in that way
but we'd have some diversity of our
culture report thank you for
understanding the question better than
the German problem
okay has anyone else got any questions
that they would like to put Council
Harvey um I don't know whether this is
relevant forgive me if it isn't
um
in dealing with applications where there
are environmental aspects concerned
um residents will have a regard
informing their views on The credibility
of the applicant can you tell us
anything about your experience and
expertise and and uh
experience of installing similar sort of
Ventures elsewhere
whilst I'm I'm perfectly happy to answer
that it's not a relevant planning uh
it's not relevant to the decision making
process
um we need to be looking at this based
on planning law if it's not I'm policy
on the basis that you have received one
of these that details a lot of what
you've asked I think that probably
answers your question so
um unless there are any other questions
no gentlemen both of you thank you very
much for your time contribution and
patience this evening
okay our last speaker on this items
councilor Parry Council Parry good
evening and welcome
so while our signs are coming up and
you're making yourself comfortable
you'll have five minutes I'll give you a
30 second warning if you stay seated
with questions afterwards whenever
you're comfortable and ready to go the
floor is yours thank you chair first
slide please
first slide please
solar energy is an important part of the
UK's strategy to cut carbon emissions
and tackle the climate emergency I am
therefore in support of your renewable
energy projects of the right size in the
right location and which avoid
destroying the character of a rural
landscape providing essential food
production consequently I have
significant concerns about this
application as you will see the site
sits at the Gateway entrance into the
ancient medieval village of Newbold PC
in the open Countryside hence my strong
objection in view of its impact on the
ancient track
e6982 White Oaks and Flint Hall next
side please
the site board is the public
right-of-way
e6982
sd128 and sd129 all over 39 hectares or
96 Acres this represents a very large
solar farm being over 25 hectares as
defined in Stratford's renewable energy
landscape sensitivity study by the white
Consultants which provided the evidence
space for sdc's core strategy to give
you a sense of its size the the
development equates to 55 football
pitches and reflects the eastern half of
wellsborn and is larger than each of
Newbold Pacey and ashhorn villages
site is now double the size originally
stated on the application form at 18
hectares which was an error and now
corrected at 39 hectares and therefore
has even greater impact in addition to
the scale the white Consultants report
identifies that solar energy
developments need to be built on on flat
Landscapes with minimal impact to the
landscape character next slide please
the site reflects the typical
large-scale rolling Topography of the
felden Parklands which is currently used
to grow much needed food crops as this
combine harvest and picture taken just
last week shows
next slide please
as well as its undulating landscape the
proposed solar panels will be installed
onto spikes at a height of 10 foot one
inch the devastation to the landscape if
granted would result in an obliteration
of this Countryside as part of the site
lies adjacent to the ancient track and
footway used daily by local residents
and Ramblers even the developers
acknowledge that the impact on the
landscape is moderate to high in my view
it is exceptionally High next slide
please
these pictures give an indication of How
High and visible the panels would be
next slide please
this is the height indicator measured
correctly as used in the pictures which
has been brought with you tonight to
give members a real indication of How
High these solar panels are we have a
measuring tape
next slide please
this map highlights the public
right-of-way by the green dots a
designated ancient track
e6982 which is verified by wcc's
definitive map next slide please
this slide shows the views from e6982
ancient track the combination of the
site's undulating landscape and higher
than normal solar panels will conflict
with this settlement's historical core
and traditional character members please
note there is no tree or hedge planting
just brush planting planned between this
track and areas four and five next slide
please
whilst highways has submitted a response
of no objection this conflicts with the
white report which advises that solar
developments can be dangerously
eye-catching when adjacent to roads the
b4087 is a black spot with a number of
recent fatalities and last month another
horrific accident occurred adjacent to
the proposed site
the trees and hedgerows which border the
b4087 are also deciduous so there will
be no leaves on trees from October to
April presenting an extremely
eye-catching sight showing massive waves
of solar panels in full view to
motorists the scale of the development
also significantly detracts the views
from Flint Hall and White Oaks
properties together with the ancient
track and footpath which are areas of
high tranquility and consequently this
application is over development out of
character with the landscape and would
cause significant harm to the setting of
this medieval village
I'm also speaking on behalf of wellsborn
and Morton moral Parish councils which
strongly object the application for a
solar farm as it is completely in the
wrong location and there are no
Community energy benefits to local
residents please do the right thing to
protect our historic landscape and
refuse this application thank you
members
okay thank you very much indeed members
do we have any questions for our board
member Council Jennings
good evening
there seemed to be 32 letters of
objection for yet 48 letters of support
So it seems to have more support than
objection
why do you think that would be
maybe Mr Jennings councilor Jennings it
may be because the letters of support
have not come from within the village I
can assure you as the ward member there
are very few properties in new bowl
Pacey and the surrounding villages
any other questions for our world member
no
apply me in that case Council price
thank you very much for your time
contribution this evening
before we move on chair can I just
strongly urge members to give no weight
to the prop used by councilor Parry to
demonstrate the height of the panels you
should rely on your own judgment and not
this sort of untested evidence to assess
the impact of the panels
it's
it's
not an appropriate way to go about it
similarly the the prop that's there you
should not give it anyway and I can
explain why if you want me to go through
the the presentation why it is
misleading to you rely on why is
evidence okay
please go back to it take me to the
photographs
we did it if you remember councilor
Mills actually on site we stood me next
to one and assessed and we decided that
I was about half the height of a 10-foot
post uh I'm six foot tall
which isn't about half the height of 10
foot
if you go down one no no down one more
here we go nope
that one
again that I'm not sure whether it's a
gentleman or lady that person appears to
be about the height of that 10-foot pole
um I'm I'm making a rash assumption that
that person isn't five feet tall and if
you look at it you can see that the pole
is on a higher level than the person who
is standing there
look at it
the person that the poll is on a higher
level than the person so use your own
judgment that's all I'm saying do not be
guided by that poll be guided by your
own judgment
thank you chair can I so this poll here
is inaccurate cancer Mills I think that
I I don't want us to get into the the
detail of that I think the point that
Council Barker is making is we clearly
sorry Mr Barker you've had an upgrade
um Mr Marcus making is that we have no
we haven't measured that now is not the
time for us to measure that you're
seeing photos here we don't know if
that's the same one so it's about
judgment
you know how tall three meters I know
how much 10 foot is it's about judgment
and there are much more planning issues
that we need to consider outside of just
that
um okay we've had our speakers we now
have punch clarification for our
officers
would anyone like anything clarified I
have a list of things we've talked about
so
I can go through those first if you
would rather
I shall do that then
um okay first one um Aviation it was
referred to earlier that uh no uh
consultation has happened with anyone in
relation to Aviation and specifically
glare on uh to to planes crossing over
the sites can you give me
um your opinion on that
thank you chairman um I refer I would
refer you and and everybody to our
consultations page uh on page 29 our
conversation summary on page 29.
um we have consulted with the
um what's listed here is and that's
safeguarding that's
um
National Air Traffic Services thank you
very much yes to do with Aviation uh the
standardized consultation for uh
Aviation matters they have been
consulted they have assessed all the uh
submitted documents including the
glincey glare analysis and are satisfied
to offer no objection
thank you very much
um we the board member referred to a
designated ancient track
um do does that way how much weight
should we give to designated tracks in
uh in the planning balance
um it is of material relevance uh it is
and remains as I understand a public
right-of-way
um some of the public rights of where
you can see displayed on your screens in
the proposed site layout plan
um officers have considered this matter
um we have also consulted with a number
of parties including Warwickshire County
public rights of way team again I urge
you to look at page 28
whereupon no objection was offered to
the County's Public rights away team
they did offer a suggested four
conditions we also consulted with the
Ramblers Association who offered uh no
objection and offered some comments
relating to the public rights of way of
which I understand e6982 has actually
been referenced
okay that's helpful thank you
um the first Speaker our first Speaker
Council Wright uh referred to a policy
within our course strategy document that
relating to the the land should be um it
should be small scale and flat landscape
um I didn't pick out exactly the policy
that related to but if you could inform
me of which policy that isn't exactly
what the wording is that would be
helpful of course yes uh that's policy
CS3 in our course strategy
um I've got a copy of it here in front
of me and Snippets and excerpts of it
have been quoted in your principle of
development section
um officers have assessed this
development against this specific policy
and other policies and development plan
have found that this proposal Accords
with policy CS through the same policy
in question
okay
um the plant proposed planting scheme
um
if we if we remind you to Grant
um is there a mechanism whereby we can
uh ensure that uh anything planted is
Evergreen or something that's that
effect of sufficient size and scale or
will grow to sufficient size and scale
in order to be able to largely screen
this but and particularly where
uh
some of the Hedgerow that is being
filled in may not take it gets replaced
and anything around it that may get
damaged as a result of the works will
also get reinstated or replaced by
something new and of worth
uh yes thank you chairman uh yes there
is certainly a mechanism that could
secure that
um I have a suggested condition five in
your on page 43 uh of your agenda packs
which would seek to secure full hard and
soft Landscaping details and full
details of uh the boundary treatment uh
to be submitted to and approved by this
District where my members minded to
Grant so yes to your question that could
be matters such as that could be secured
through planning condition as
appropriate
um perhaps to add to that chair
um we could also possibly ask the
applicant to do a condition survey of
the hedges to make sure that we weren't
being misled by the fact that it's a
dead hedge full of Ivy uh and in the
event that dead hedging or dead sections
are identified they could be replanted
and I feel sure the applicant wouldn't
object to that and it it seems like a
perfectly reasonable addition to the
condition that's exactly what orange is
here so thank you very much for that
that exhausts the list that I've got
from you all Council Rock
uh thank you chair just a couple of
questions
um pertaining to the remark from the
Ramblers which
I just want to understand I've got this
correct the Rambler appear to have asked
for five meters clear width
retained for
e6982 which I think is the ancient Rogue
that's been referred to along the north
the northern boundary of the site which
we looked at on the site visit
probably could withdraw that remark then
uh it's this clear boundary because I've
scaled the one on the North aside from
them and it appears to be 20 meters
clear so
um uh I'm looking for that clearance
that's set back from the right away on
the Northern side
um is that something we should condition
or do we assume this drawing is
absolutely accurate from the last solar
panel so I have to take that first
because it looks like I've got the wrong
location my colleagues pointing
somewhere else that's quite the right
thank you uh councilor I think I would
defer a little bit to my previous answer
in that full details of boundary
treatments could be and will be where
your mind is approve would be secured
via conditions so absolute Clarity would
be provided virus a planning condition
that's the exact distances to ensure
that comments are offered by the
Ramblers are Incorporated in the scheme
in addition to the four suggested
conditions by public rights of way which
have been included on your suggested
conditions thank you chairman my second
point
is probably fairly fundamental
we've identified this causes less than
substantial harm
but we recognize that the development is
temporary
for a 40-year period
now my question for the officers
is obviously we're saying 40 years is a
temporary period
up I've not got 40 years left to go so
um perhaps I can help councilman in
terms of the medieval village in terms
of the listed buildings 40 years is a
relatively short period in their life
right
I'm not listed you're not listening
neither am I
think maybe
neither am I fully reversible you know
the comment is accepting that it's a
40-year period and 40 years is a long
time okay but uh in terms of impact on
the Heritage asset uh over the period of
the life of the Heritage asset 40 years
is is recognized if it wanted to be
extended that would be a new application
that is not before us correct correct
thank you I also thank my colleague as
well um it's my understanding that
40-year period is fairly commonplace for
solar farm developments uh the
technology where they have a lifespan of
40 years uh of being able to generate
our assumption here is
for our decision today is that 40 years
that the whole scheme would be removed
correct and again there's a condition uh
two on your suggested conditions ensures
that it is a temporary vision and that
in full accordance with the
decommissioning plan these solar panels
would be then removed from site okay
thank you chairman
members do we have any other accounts of
Curtis thank you
um just going back Stuart you you
referred to policy CS3
um and small scale I just
does that policy give any indication of
if I've understood this correctly of
what small scale is in this context
thank you councilor um the short answer
in the purposes of this policy is that
no there is no provision given as to
what constitutes small scale and what
constitutes large scale that's not
uncommon for
um planning policy of of this
description it allows
um elements of interpretation it allows
each and every scheme to be considered
its own merits
um it cannot give a prescriptive figure
or a percentage to say what would be
considered to be large scale and what
would be considered to be small scale
so one we could then and this would be
perhaps more for debate taken to account
the context of the size of this on its
local environment
uh yes that's correct yes
councilor Harvey
purposes amongst the team had been
involved in arriving at this
recommendation
please
uh you can't yes myself principally as
case officer my manager who helped me is
actually sent to my right this evening
is involved we have liaised with our
conservation colleagues as well who have
visited sites separately
um there have been then offices clearly
involved at Warwickshire County who have
been consulted and we've been uh as is
commonplace for a Play application for
the purposes of Stratford then our own
District uh the officers who I've just
named were the principal people involved
um environmental health yes the team
leader uh yes yes or Consultants as are
listed in your consultation summary have
been Consulting on this application
Edition
okay
any further
points of clarification to our officers
before we move into the debates
no right let's open up debate who would
like to kick us off
I'll start picking on people if they
don't put a hand up councilor Jennings
mm-hmm
and it's normally me so I started off
coffee stations have been taken out of
mothballs in the UK Germany and other
countries
um
well I think the last few weeks have
shown us what what's happening with the
clan with with the climate emergency
we have to act on it
um
and we've got to do something which is
more green and no matter how much how
painful for it is
um
we have a guest destroyed the world and
we've got we've now got to pay the piper
um we've got to take these difficult
decisions and they're not popular
um but they still have to be made
um
at the moment I am in I am very much
leaning in favor of the officer's
recommendation but I shall come back to
that later in the debate that's not a
proposal yet not yet okay thank you very
much Council Fleming
um sort of driving around this area in
the last couple of weeks we see what the
farmers are doing and
as the only member of the climate change
panel here
um I think that I've got to look at a
very balanced View
declaring war on Farmers by Mr Norris
statements about they're doing this
wrong they're doing that wrong they're
doing the next thing wrong we need to
eat okay we need to pair our Teslas and
all those sort of cars but we need to
eat and from what I can see saying that
this is poor grade land that's a fella
so you've seen the quality of the crops
that was growing in those fields so from
that perspective I see it as a balance
do we really want to lose that land
to free electricity or should we really
be looking after the Heritage that we've
got I mean with them we're a really good
agricultural area and I don't think we
should be burying it under
um solar panels so at the moment I'm
going slightly against what to
cancer Jennings has said so far
okay thank you very much Council Andrew
Sarah thank you sir
um I'm not against solar panels
in the wrong place I am and we should
not be using agricultural land as we
only produce 40 of our food and I feel
that we will need to produce more food
in the future
um I've always
at the idea of solar panels on top of
Supermarket car parks
I think we should insist more on
Developers
where they build quite a number of
houses to use solar panels they're not
contributing to any of that so um
I'm leaning against Refuge
thank you very much
I'll come back to you cancer genius
cancer Mills
yes thanks Mr chairman yeah it is a
question of balance isn't it on this
um there's um Peter's saying we need to
grow the food we need an energy
um
I I to be honest I feel uncomfortable
about this application Mr chairman
um
I can see lots of reasons I put down
here why
I will object to it I shall listen to
what other people say on the panel thank
you Mr Chen
thank you very much councilor Jennings
yeah I mean I've looked into the
fallacy that you can just put solar
panels on top of Tescos and other areas
and other buildings commercial buildings
like that it simply doesn't work
um if you do put them on top of
commercial buildings it adds value to
them and that increases their rates
um so therefore they get a rate increase
and quite often landlords put
stipulations in tenancy agreements that
they have to put them back to where they
were when they when they're first taken
on which then puts an additional cost
onto the onto the the owner or the
tenant to put them on and take them off
and it also creates issues with the
landlords and tenants on insurance of
the roof so it's a complete Minefield
you can't just turn around and say Well
it has to go on top of buildings instead
it has to go somewhere and it has to go
somewhere it has to go now now is the
time when we have to make the difference
cancer Curtis
I'm sorry thank you
um just picking up very briefly on the
last couple of speakers I think we are
in slight danger of being diverted from
the application in front of us
um I feel this is a real Judgment of
Solomon I mean I listened to what Simon
garage said with a great deal of
interest and I think the the points he
makes are very eloquent about the mono
culture that is so much modern
agribusiness and I want to but could we
is it possible to bring up the sort of
locations slide that shows this this
site in relation to new gold Pacey and
wellsborn thank you
my real I mean I I hear all the
arguments on both sides and I'm
really very torn
I think what does concern me though is
when talking about scale
when we look at this site the scale of
it in comparison to new bold PC and even
to wellsborn
it does seem
just out of proportion and I I hear what
the officer was saying that it it that
there is no definitive measure of what
is small and large scale and I I can
understand why it is a matter of context
but I'm concerned that in this context
this is actually of an overwhelming
scale to the local Villages thank you
chair
thank you very much councilor Curtis can
you turn your microphone off please
um you did beat me to the punch I was
going to get this in my summing up but
um a lot of what was talked about is not
relevant to this planning application so
I'll just again reiterate what's been
said we must focus on what's contained
with this in within this report and
what's relevant to this planning
application not the peripherals I'll
come back to you in a second Catherine
Jennings cancer Dixon
thank you chairman uh there was a lot to
talk about uh landscape uh matters uh in
this presentation
um we've got the green belt
part of this District we've got the
Cotswold aob part of this district and
we've got special landscape areas as
part of this District
I don't think this land is in any of
those elements
so I'm the councilor Jennings
it's the situation I feel whereby This
Land Is Not First Quality agricultural
land we do need who start
regenerating electricity with solar and
with wind
personally I prefer solar to wind
turbine on land at least obviously wind
turbine out at Sea is a different matter
we've got an application here for what I
think is essentially required and I will
actually support the officer's
recommendation and I will make the
proposal that we Grant
thank you very much Council Dixon
councilor Jennings
to the points then
um
there's there are emotional reasons to
object to this but we're not here to
make judgments on emotions we're here to
make judgments on sound material
planning reasons
um there's no loss of agricultural land
the biodiversity benefits are there and
you can put sheep on this there is no
loss of agricultural land it's a
temporary measure and there's going to
be Woodland screening
um I'm happy to second the motion that
we go with the office of recommendation
to Grant
okay thank you very much both of you um
do we have anyone else who wants to
speak in the debate
no um
I'm going to add to your
uh proposal and secondary I'm going to
request that you um include Within
I think it was condition five hard and
soft Landscaping details and full
boundary treatment detail to include a
conditioned survey of all the trees and
the hedgerows on the site
are you happy with that both of you
could you say that verbally please
perfectly happy with that chairman I'm
happy with that well done thank you very
much both of you
okay
um unless anyone else does want to speak
and this is your opportunity to do so
we will move to a vote because we have a
proposal that has been seconded so the
proposal is to Grant application
220003 ful Lander Elms Farm Newbold Road
in line with the officer's
recommendation with the addition uh to
condition number five could I have a
show of hands of volumes in favor of
granting please
seventh
seven and those against
and any abstentions
no in that case committee resolves two
grants application 22 is zero zero zero
zero three ful land Elms Farm new bold
facie uh we have been going for an hour
and 15 minutes I'm going to propose that
we have a two minute adjournment to
allow people to exit the chamber but
also for our own comfort so please be
back as quickly as you can
okay ladies and gentlemen we are now all
back and ready to go so if I could ask
you to take your seats and Peter
thank you very much indeed okay so our
next item this evening is uh application
reference 2102 589 ful that is hogwood
Farm in pillow and Hersey sorry building
Hershey Road in oxhill uh are presenting
officer Charlotte dick Charlotte over to
you
thank you very much chair
so the site is indicated on the map by
the black circle the application site is
located to the north of the a422 and
access from the Kyneton road which is
situated to the east of the site the
site is within the open Countryside
this slide shows the applications I
edged in red it forms parts of a pig
rearing Enterprise which is part of a
wider 220 acre agricultural unit
the buildings that you can see within
the site are agricultural
the ground level rises towards the north
of the site
so this is a full planning application
for the Redevelopment of the pig sheds
and direction of 10 new four bed
dwellings the plan on the left hand side
of the screen shows the existing site
with the pig farm sheds tightly knit on
the southern part of the site the plan
on the right hand side shows the
proposed 10 dwellings with Associated
Garden space and paraphernalia bending
and outbuildings wind turbines are also
proposed vehicular access is proposed to
the east of the site from Kyneton Road
to give you an idea of the variety of
design between the 10 dwellings that I
proposed I've included some elevation
drawings
this plan shows the proposed Northern
elevation of plots two and three plot
two can be seen on the left with plot
three on the right hand side
and you can see the proposed wind
turbines
this plan shows the proposed west
elevation of plot four with the silo
part of the design included
this plan shows the proposed South
elevation of plot six
and this slide shows the north elevation
of plot 10.
so this photo is taken from the
crossroads to the south of the site the
position is shown by the map in the
corner of the screen with the red arrow
indicating the way we are facing the a42
sorry a422 is visible in the foreground
with Kyneton Road leading away from us
the first access into the site is
visible
um but it's located approximately where
the tree can be seen on the left hand
side of Clinton Road
this photo is taken from further up
Clinton Road Again indicated by the map
in the corner in the array the tree is
now visible centrally in the photo the
first axis is visible just beyond these
trees and you can see some of the
Agricultural buildings on the left hand
side of the photo
foreign
the photo shows the first access into
the site from Kyneton road with the farm
buildings visible then this photo has
taken traveling further up kindton road
with a site now on the right hand side
looking back down Clinton Road to the
South
as shown by the arrow you can see the
established hedge line in the photo
between the two access points
and then this photo is a longer distance
view taken as you travel along the a422
traveling East you can see in the farm
buildings fairly centrally within the
image and the blue ra which you should
be able to see
um indicates the approximate extent to
the site
and then this photo is taken from
outside Redwings rescue center looking
back towards the site and we're facing
west along the a42 now
the farm visible at buildings are
visible centrally
so just to clarify there are updates
within the update sheet which includes
revised Consulting responses from the
llfa and Street Scene so officer
recommendation is to refuse the
application for redevelopment of the pig
farm to create 10 new dwellings in line
with the reasons and note on the pages
65 and 66 of the agenda thank you chair
oh thank you very much indeed let's call
our first speaker on this item who is
councilor Ian Brooks of pilot and Hersey
Parish Council
good evening and thank you for your
patience
so you should have a reasonable idea of
what's happening now you'll have three
minutes I'll give you 30 second warning
and once you're settled and comfortable
if you press the button in the middle
it'll turn red and the floor will be
yours
good evening chair thank you Pennington
Hersey Parish Council supports the
application we're aware that Ox Hill
Parish Council which in proximity terms
is much closer to the site is also in
favor
regarding the development developed
nature of the land Hogwart Farm is a
small site dedicated to the Intensive
rearing of pigs
is licensed to house fifteen thousand
pigs within specially constructed or
adapted buildings supported by a complex
feeding system first impressions are not
of a typical farming operation but one
that is rather more closely relaxed
related to a factory star operation
at times the pungent smell undermines
the enjoyment of the Residential
Properties in fillers and Hersey
depending on the wind direction some two
miles away
smell is more of an issue to those
living and working closer in oxhill
vehicle movements to and from the
premises associated with the feeding
regime
in terms of materials and the movement
of pigs are significant
slide two if you would use car
The Farmstead tile style development
proposal making use of a range of
materials with its emphasis on
traditional buildings to enhance a
landscape views rather than detract from
it
this element has been commented on very
positively by many local residents 50
letters of support with no own
objections is unusual
there's a clear preference for the
proposed development over currently what
is in place
in sustainability terms
the development promises to implement
high standard insulation grounds Hall
seating shared access to the wind
turbines and I'll come back to this
business and shared rapid charging for
electric vehicles batteries
Etc are very encouraging to see
on-site greed energy production is
predicted to provide the equivalent of a
total annual requirements for four to
five houses so that's half already
operating nil impact use of solar
there's currently 200 solar panels on
two of the buildings might enable this
unique development to be completely
self-sufficient and exciting opportunity
energy security through a combination of
reduced demand and control of Health
generation can make a positive
contribution to our climate action
change program 30 seconds
finally our mentioned shared use of the
wind generated energy this was an
exciting inclusion in the proposed plan
when I first heard of it
the developers intention to create a
community with shared interests a mutual
joint benefits is a potential Game
Changer thank you
Council thank you very much indeed
members do you have any questions
for our counselor
no
okay in that case Council Brooks thank
you very much for your time contribution
and of course your patience as well
okay our next speaker on this item uh is
Mark wildish the agent and Brian hobbill
is that have I pronounced that correct
good evening and welcome I believe Brian
is our applicant
uh I believe you're here to answer
questions is that right
marvelous it's Mr Wallace you'll have
three minutes I'll give you 30 second
warning when uh we're getting towards
the end of your time we'll put up
anything
we'll we'll see if we can find that just
bear with us
foreign
the existing concrete covered site is
not a stereotypical idyllic Farmstead it
is a densely developed Pig Factory it is
neither green nor a field but an
industrialized production line and
clearly previously developed land
based on a Farmstead built around a new
nature Pond our proposed Redevelopment
with its traditional looking farm
buildings and two earthbank houses
incorporating wind turbines made this
proposal both visually and
environmentally enhancing
described by John Gordon the enabling
officer as very refreshing the
development specifically complies with
seven local and 13 nppf policies with 52
letters two Parish councils two Ward
members and the cpra all supporting The
Proposal with not a single objection the
support for this proposal is
unprecedented and must tell you that
this proposal is appropriate
the pig sheds have a singly use and
planners accept that they cannot be used
for any other purpose
completely different to the home drum
developments that are flying up across
the district Stand Out exemplary
projects that demonstrate we can and
must do better and needed if standards
are to improve and I believe that this
proposal could be one such example
since 2017 vegan activists have targeted
the farm with repeated organized
protests and only today Mr hobby will
received a hoax call and was broken into
on Sunday
the farm is no longer financially viable
and with a tarnished reputation can it
be sold as a going concern
despite passing every government
inspection required the actions against
the farm led to the loss of Mr hobbels
Tesco contract and red tractor
accreditation resulting in every Pig
costing more money to produce than they
can be sold the planners have put their
faith in the Liz Allen landscape report
but the report is fundamentally flawed
since it fails to make a comparison
between the visual impact of the
existing pig farm and our proposal
despite repeatedly asking the planners
have refused to answer the simple yes or
no question is the existing pig farm
visually more attractive than our
proposal our submitted lbia does make
the comparison and reaches the logical
conclusion that the existing pig farm is
visually more harmful than the proposed
scheme which will be an enhancement
opinion that is shared by the supporters
of the scheme
there is no objection in principle from
the llfa and it is a matter of agreeing
technical specification the waste and
recycling offices revise objection which
was dropped on us today
is not insurmountable and both could be
dealt with by condition with an unfairly
negative case officer's report that
contains five mistakes and a neglects to
mention many of the positives about this
application three minutes is simply not
enough time to respond and so I kindly
invite your questions in particular
respect to the protests Landscaping
previously developed land flooding and
the errors in the officers report thank
you very much thank you very much indeed
members do we have any questions for our
applicant and agent
Council Curtis
thank you
um thank you very much
I'm sorry I didn't quite catch you you
mentioned that I think the words we you
used something had been dropped on you
today but I didn't quite catch what that
was could you elaborate a little please
uh yes thank you
[Music]
I raised
what's last week that the information
contained with in her officer's report
relating to the objection from the waste
and recycling officer which was dated
the 17th of February had been superseded
by a revised plan and the report refers
to one of my drawings
21363-123 D whereas actually we
submitted a plan 23 E that was approved
by the highways department and was also
meant to address the objections from the
waste and recycling officer now
subsequently today we have received an
email from Charlotte dated the 28th of
July as a new Fresh
um slight update from the waste and
recycling officer and yet that calls
into question why does the officer's
report refer back to the 17th of
February a rich original objection if
Charlotte did speak to them on the 28th
I think we'll probably try and clarify
that later on in points clarification
councilor Jennings
okay Council Jennings has retracted his
so any other questions for our two
speakers
no in that case gentlemen both of you
thank you very much for your time and
patience this evening and of course your
contribution just now
thank you
okay our next and final speaker on this
item is a counselor Anthony Anne
O'Donnell
good evening
and welcome you know the drill so
whenever you're set up ready and take as
much time as you need you'll have five
minutes I'll give you 30 second one in
four times up and as soon as you settled
and press the button in the middle I
shall start the timer
good evening committee
um can I ask have many of you had the
opportunity to visit
the farm the site how many have actually
been
okay right the reason I ask is that if
you're in any doubt as to the previously
developed land status that should be
afforded to this site then your decision
should really be deferred until you've
been on the site visit
um then you will see firsthand the
extent of development on the site which
the slides did outline to some extent it
is as you've seen farming on an
industrial scale quite different to your
typical Farm instead and it's visually
detrimental and intensively developed
and to be quite Frank it's really ugly
no offense to the applicant so I would
ask you to not consider this as an
application within picturesque open
Countryside it is far from that I would
however committee ask you to put
yourself into the mindset of the
applicant who up until a few years ago
focused on building a pig farming
business which his son whose always also
an award-winning pig farmer would then
continue once those retirement years
beckoned it was a successful business
and he took great pride in what he'd
built up over Decades of really hard
work
fast forward now and you'll see before
you an applicant who as you've heard his
farm has been broken into 38 times the
last time being on Sunday protesters
have targeted his business and the
situation is such now that he and his
wife have to leave their home drive to a
place of safety to watch the break-in
and vandalism happening via their CCTV
footage powerless to do anything so just
imagine how you would feel leaving the
comfort of your home to sit in a car and
view the destruction of your business
and livelihood also the applicant is his
pigs are fetching less than the average
price consistently because the targeting
Relentless protests have impacted upon
his accreditation status
therefore diversification is the only
responsible option and this application
has been front loaded with overwhelming
support from both pilot and Hersey and
oxhill Parish Council compare this with
the overwhelming objection seen with the
Redevelopment of wixley's Transport yard
a Brownfield site only 300 yards from
this Farm local people want this to
happen nobody has objected and while the
government plans Street votes already
introduced this scheme would be
unanimously approved the this applicant
has proactively worked with the local
community now when we're considering
this visual impact of an application you
surely have to compare it with what is
already there and converted farmsteads
of large rural residents are a common
feature in the surrounding landscape
the proposed design is based on the
character of such an isolated farmstead
and the applicant and agent worked
closely with the local community to
create a proposal that is contextually
in keeping whilst also Innovative and
forward-looking incorporating features
such as the work from home offices we
now all utilize and the energy efficient
design
the fabric First Construction will be
adopted for each of the ten homes which
means that each will incorporate much
higher than required details for
insulation than are required by the
building regulation standards so
therefore utilizing high energy
retention insulation products this
design is exciting it's our opportunity
in Pilot and Hersey to lead on a Grand
Design standard development and we
believe that the design approach in
ethos of creating consciously sustained
sustainable development is exceptional
and therefore complies with the as10
indeed as you've heard John Gordon the
enabling officer describe the site as
very refreshing
there have been numerous other intensive
pig farms being redeveloped for
residential purposes up and down the
country from Greenview Farm County
Durham where 12 dwellings were approved
to larger Farm in Suffolk with five
dwellings but this application before
you is smaller than that of birchwell
Road in watlington where 183 houses were
approved there's just a point I'd like
to address from Charlotte's report
around the flooding bearing in mind that
seven Trent have not lodged Emily
objection to the site the existing site
is all Concrete Hard standing and
buildings and drains to a single point
in an existing ditch historically there
has never been any record of the sites
having flooded or caused flooding
elsewhere and with two attenuation ponds
and returning most of the site back to
green this can only result in betterment
if you look at the Liz Allen landscape
report paragraph 3.4.3 it acknowledges
that replace the existing buildings
would result in some benefits 30 seconds
redeveloping the site as proposed with
accorded policies CS2 CS3 both on the
benefits of removing the many vehicle
movements which on average is
2872 per year for the farm if it was
residential that would average around
between 650 and 700 so a massive
reduction there
and also it would reduce the Farm's
operation from the efficient energy
performance and the proposed designs
Mark has already covered the refuse and
waste officers comments
wrap up with a final comment please I
would just urge you committee to view
this application with the compassion
that it truly deserves and the human
story behind it
thank you very much councilor members do
we have any questions for our Ward
member Council Rock please
uh thank you chairman
good evening Council O'Donnell uh just
to pick out one of your points uh
as10
contains a clause in it for exceptional
dwellings
is that the one I don't want to say
you're hanging your hat on is that the
is that the exception that you're
picking in there exceptional
um
I I can't remember the phrase because I
can't
got the photographic the Clause I think
you've asked that's the one that you're
picking on you're suggesting we should
consider
thank you
okay do we have any other questions
Council Fleming
looking at this this establishment as it
is there are no other uses that this can
be put to either so that's that's why I
mean after after the sort of attacks by
the the
the V army if you like
um I don't like using the word
um
forced this guy into a business that you
can't maintain it's not sustainable but
there's no other use for the buildings
you're quite right I understand that the
back story mace I can see you looking
um puzzled is is the backstory obviously
is not a planning reason but it's what's
Driven this diversification application
you're quite right counselor so I mean
that they cannot reuse these buildings
for anything else that you know they we
have it has to be redeveloped
okay any other questions cancer Crump
thank you Mr chairman uh just a couple
of questions uh councilor Donald uh
firstly where are the nearest houses
shops and doctors to this application
site please
well um I would suggest that it's going
to be ships done for doctors is for
everybody in the bulletins or there may
be some that got their doctors in
wellsborn but that's as it is for all
the bulletin Villages so it's no less
sustainable I know what you're driving
out of the question than it is for the
other the other residents in politen
Hersey and what about the shops and the
houses how close I met I heard one of
the previous speakers say they're
affected potentially by the smile but I
just he didn't indicate how far away
those houses were I would ask if we can
actually check that with Charlotte
yeah
okay probably a bit of both between
sales and officers so I want to do as
well
um regarding the flooding
um
there was a point you mentioned about
Charlotte uh in the report but on I
think on page 60 the league lead local
for the minor maintained our objection
to the application because not suitable
insufficient information has been
submitted
um so that's I think that's there's I've
got some concern about that
why that wasn't potentially overcome
before it became to the planning
committee and I can I can understand as
well with your portfolio at County where
you'd have an insight into this
councilor Crump and um obviously we do
not want flooding but there has been no
episodes of flooding I understand
um there's no historical evidence of
flooding and I would suggest that that
is a discussion that could happen
in advance that this this application
actually starting and get the details
that you need I can't answer why that
hasn't been fulfilled I would suggest
that possibly one for the agent rather
than myself because I don't want to
misinform you okay
anyone else with a question for our Ward
member please
no in that case councilor Jones thank
you very much for your contribution your
time and your patience
now we're going to go to
um points clarification to our officers
but I just remind members that we are
here to make a decision on a planning
application based on national and local
planning policy we've heard a lot about
emotive and how we feel we're here to
make decisions on planning policy I just
wanted to remind you of that because we
have strayed a few times
now do we have any questions and put
some clarification councilor Harvey
first please yes the paperwork makes
reference to uh brownfield's site
um and I'd like to establish whether the
officers regardless as Brownfield or
open Countryside and I refer
specifically as has been mentioned in
the paperwork to as11
and as11 at paragraph 6 13 7
says Under The Heading as11 large rural
Brownfield sites says the four specific
sites covered in the policy and then
goes on that leads me to believe that
as11
applies only to the four specified sites
if is that correct if that is correct
this isn't Brownfield
would I then be correct in assuming that
this is therefore open Countryside
so to answer your questions we do
consider that the site is in the open
Countryside and because it is
agricultural land it is excluded from
being considered as previously developed
land in accordance with the mppf so
because we cannot consider it as
previously developed land as-10 sorry
as11 would not be relevant in this case
at all
so just be absolutely clear councilor
Harvey by definition if it's used for
growing food it isn't previously
developed land pigs are food
it doesn't matter that it might look
like previously developed land it
doesn't meet the definition we can't
modify or adjust the definition that is
the definition and it doesn't meet it
thank you very much any other points of
clarification before I go through my
list Council Rock uh perhaps I'm reading
this incorrectly bottom of page 52 the
northern of the site consists of pasture
land storage areas including the
existing Bank
what precisely does that mean
the Alka Bond yes it's just a small
Earth Bank to the northern part of the
design okay thank you
Council Dixon
thank you chairman
um obviously we do have a policy to
permit exceptional dwellings of design
Etc in the open Countryside
can that apply to a group of dwellings
so policy
as10j makes specific reference to a
single dwelling in open Countryside
which is of exceptional quality and
design and makes a positive contribution
to the character of the local area so it
does specifically say a single dwelling
so it wouldn't be relevant in this case
Council cases I wrote your name down
because you had something you wanted
clarifying earlier and I can't remember
what it was do you remember
sorry to put you on the spot like that I
tell you what do you think about that
while you think about that we're going
to go to councilor Crump who wanted
something about flooding I believe
yeah um
I'll give you a bit of time um very
briefly
um Charlotte
um
it was just about
the yellow
if I still got their objection in
because I haven't got enough information
and I think it's is it called strategy
policy is it for somewhere that this is
a strong re sorry I'm right it's a
reason is one of your reasons for refuse
doesn't it
yes that's correct um so some additional
information was received from the
applicant at the end of last week which
was referred onto the llfa and they did
come back with a sorry revised
consultation response yesterday
confirming that they maintained their
objection
um for a number of reasons which are
included in in the update sheet
um I believe that Council Crump also
asked a question earlier about distances
to shops and doctors who've had an
opportunity to find out roughly the
distance to shops and doctors please
foreign
but my question to one of the speakers
was um that they'd received some an
update of details today and then it was
concerning I believe waste and recycling
um I remember what this is now so this
is the emails uh and um responses to
consultation to the waste and recycling
group and you're going to wait and we
want clarification we want clarification
on when that came in and how it works
I'll cover that once we've got the
distances to shops and things
I think perhaps Joe we're talking about
distance to the nearest settlement if
that's the the measurement you're
looking for isn't it distance to the
nearest settlement I I think what cancer
Crump was looking for was specifically
to shops so an assessment I'm I'm
assuming councilman forgive me for
putting words in your mouth uh an
assessment of
um
sustainability was I was about to say
viability that's the wrong one of
sustainability
okay
um
I think I might be able to do that
differently to how these folks are doing
it and perhaps get to a quicker decision
while you do that I'm going to refer
councilor Curtis to the update sheet you
can see um on the bottom there second
from bottom paragraph Street Scene 28th
to the 7th 22 talks about the swept
analysis and the collection vehicles I
think that specifically is what you're
referring to
yes so it's on on that topic there was a
later submission of information
um and a later response
this is on it's okay this one's on
um
Charlotte you'll correct me if I'm wrong
the comment in the committee report was
up to date at the time it was written
but the date was out of date at that
time it was a typing error
I think that's our answer isn't it when
the officer report was written it was
based on the previous comments so since
the report was finalized and the agenda
had gone to print we
um we've had the comments in since then
for absolute Clarity the last uh
response we've had from street scene in
relation to refuse and waste management
uh was on the 28th of the 7th 22 and
that is the paragraph that is in our
update sheet that's correct and that's
what we rely on thank you
so I'm able to answer the question in
terms of the distance yes please now
um so it looks to be about 2.3 miles
from the site to the shop in taiso and
it's approximately 5.5 miles from the
site to um shipston so where the doctors
would be located
thank you very much marvelous
um okay and I've got my I'm I'm assuming
no one else has any points of
clarification sorry cancer Jennings
yeah
um is there any fallback on any of the
buildings for instance
agricultural buildings class Q is there
anything like that in play here or not
there's no class queue up applications
that have been determined on the site
that we would be able to take into
account as part of a fullback position
no
okay unless anyone has anything I've got
one more point I want to ask
um Council Donald let me finish this
section and then I'll come to you
um we uh within the report you talk
about um cs22 loss of business that
obviously is part of the planning
balance that we need to weigh uh when we
come into our decision we would normally
get a kernan's report I don't
specifically see reference to it there
but I'm assuming we've had one
um is that quite clear and unequivocal
uh that um this business
is or isn't a viable business can you
give me an outline and understanding of
that please
yes of course chair so we have had
comments from our agricultural
Consultants so it's Robert fox in this
case and the um based on the information
that was submitted so some financial
information has been submitted for us to
assess as part of the application but
that but based on the information it's
insufficient for us to be able to
actually assess that fully
um to back at the fact that the business
whether it's viable or not so
um in this case that's why officers have
considered that the loss of the business
is not supported in terms of cs22
okay that's helpful thank you
um councilor Donald you've signed that
you'd like to have another uh bite of
the Cherry so to speak you can come
forward but you can only speak on points
of fact
thank you chair this is just to clarify
around the um sustainability question
that councilor Crump had asked I omitted
um Kyneton which is three miles where
there is the shop and the doctors as
well that's where most people would go
not shipston okay thank you
okay I'm gonna assume there are no
further points of clarification that
have Arisen since before no good let's
move into debates who would like to kick
us off councilman Mills please
thank you Mr chairman yeah I I know this
site for many years I've lived in the
area for many years
um yeah
part of the planet because there's lots
of business I I know there is a loss
um and it's been mentioned before uh
that lots of Tesco's um contract
um
personally I think this is a good scheme
I think you've got all the um
credentials there
you've got um
uh you've got solar panels you've got
your wind turbine
it's a very very it's a very nice
looking site and it would improve on
what is there and and this this is about
where uh how far away from the Dobson
schools and so on that applies to many
many villages in in uh in our district
where there's a few miles away luckily
I've been kind and I've got shops and
schools which is unusual so Mr chairman
I I think this is a very very good
scheme and um I will uh go against it
with his recommendation on this one Mr
chairman thank you thank you councilman
Claire are you making a proposal
okay I'm going to need you to start
thinking about your reasons for going
against officer's recommendation please
Council Curtis before we before we go on
before councilor Curtis um makes his
comments can I remind members that
you're considering here a planning
application for the construction of
houses in the open Countryside and you
should be considering how this proposal
meets your policies
there are we've heard many many things
this afternoon but very little has been
on how this proposal addresses your
policies
thank you very much that is very helpful
and it's quite right um we do of course
need to wait for Council Mills to give
his reasons for going against policy
um and we will seek those later as
you've heard councilor Curtis please
thanks Jeff
I think this is a highly imaginative
development that appears to be of
exceptional design
we spent a lot of time with the previous
application
I'm talking about the need to address
climate change at the last planning
committee meeting approval was given to
a house at the top of Borden Hill
specifically on exceptional design and
the fact that it was going to be
extremely environmentally friendly
this application in front of us has
support from Oxford Parish Council
Bluffton Hershey Parish Council it has
Ward member support it has adjoining
Ward member support 52 letters of
support including one from cpre
um
and I would certainly be very much with
respecting obviously the officer's
recommendation I would like to find
grounds for supporting this application
thank you chair are you just I want to
be clear are you seconding councilor
mills's proposal Yes again I'm going to
ask between you and Council come up with
very clear reasons as to why you're
going against the officer's
recommendation Council Rock
thank you chairman I think we've we've
got a heart and head problem here
um it clearly uh the presentations we've
seen today
show that um
the appearance certainly and probably
the operation uh any layperson looking
at this would say in this particular
scheme it's going to look better
for the environment and the appearance
than it is at the moment
however as the guidance we've just
received
shows
we can't drive a horse and cart through
our policies
on the basis this is development in the
open Countryside
I was exploring the is-10j situation
this exceptional design
we've heard the officers say it doesn't
comply with that
now I've got a very raw reward I have
got
a pig farming business in it which I
know is is a struggling basis but if
we're going to say well if a business is
struggling therefore we can come up with
residential development in the open
Countryside because that's not working
we really haven't got a planning policy
structure anymore so I've got a great
deal of Sympathy for the applicants in
this case and the communities that are
supporting it
but I can't see a way that our planning
policy
allows that
so I would be really struggling
to vote for the proposals that are just
on the table for us because I don't
think
we can set this precedent to do it and
uh I
you know
reluctantly feel I wouldn't be able to
support the proposals that have just
been made and uh I think we've got to go
with common sense head we we've got to
protect our uh our policy and
development the open Countryside And if
every time an agricultural business says
we we can't make it work we're going to
allow housing we haven't got a policy
anymore so uh I'm afraid I wouldn't be
able to support the proposals that have
been made thank you chairman Council
Rochester again so I've been clear in
the same way I've dealt with the other
speakers is that proposal to refuse and
I'm in the office recommendation
well I think we've got a proposal
haven't we do that we do but you can put
a count of one now I I would propose
that we uh support the officer's
recommendation thank you very much
before I come in would anyone else like
to say anything
oh everyone brilliant
cancer Fleming
um just just strikes me that through no
fault of his own that the man that owns
this Farm
um now no longer has a sustainable
business and taking counselor rocket
point every time somebody's in trouble
we shouldn't be letting them shut their
Farm down and build a house with it but
at the same time
just looking at this plan and and sort
of taking into the fact that it's carbon
neutral it ticks all the boxes from the
climate change situation but it makes
life
more pleasant for all the people who
live around it
um
I would support this system uh so I'd go
against the opposite recommendation
because
we we've just you know 20 minutes ago we
passed uh
an application to to put things on 97
hectare 97 acres of land and this is a
small plot that really isn't that big
there's a good S1 s106 potential
contribution and I'll be going along
with the support of Casey mills's
proposal
okay thank you very much councilor
Harvey I'm very much with with the
councilor Rock
um I I feel for the the applicant in the
circumstances he finds himself
but uh this is not a Brownfield site it
is an agricultural undertaking it is in
open Countryside and if we approve this
as Council rockers said we will have
effectively no policy to control uh
development in the open Countryside
thank you chair
um I'm more on the side of councilors
Harvey and rock I have to say my main
issue is that whilst I'm I like the
scheme
um I can't find enough evidence within
what we've been given and that to
overcome all of the condition
um reasons for a refusal and there there
seem to be parts of that still
outstanding from even from the after the
update sheet so you know it's almost if
we could have seen that by now we we
might have had something to
to go with the supporters with but
that's not there for me right now so I'm
going to go with the officer's
recommendation thank you very much
councilor Dixon thank you chairman I'm
with the officer's recommendation as
well it is a situation policy at the
present time says we can't really do
this one in accordance with our current
policy policy has been reviewed new
local plan is being drawn up I may be a
few years away but hopefully in the new
local plan uh exceptional schemes of an
environmental nature will get supported
but for now it can't be thank you
thank you very much Council Jennings
I think it's pretty much what everyone
else has said I mean I like the scheme I
think it looks great
um
I think the application needs a bit of
polishing four out of the five
objections could go with a bit of
polishing and it'd then be down to just
the objection number two and I think
that could be open for
debate and it'd be a lot closer than it
is
um
so regrettably I would go with the
officer's recommendation on this one
thank you very much Council Crump
Mr chairman I know the warden member
started off at the start of the
presentation about if you hadn't seen
the site visit you know you're about to
tell what sort of site it was
um
and it's certainly fault
that we were oh I think this is
premature this application
um it's not proved the viability the
evidence of the application and that's
been made perfectly clear in the
officer's recommendation in the
officer's report so again why wasn't
that done
and if that was so therefore I think the
application was brought in too early by
not providing that evidence we've still
got the flooding objection which is my
portfolio at the county side I'll get
sorts all sorts of emails not at the
moment as you can well imagine regarding
flooding but later yeah probably
tomorrow late in the year so you know
I've I've that concerns me and that
objection still withstand so that's two
reasons
thirdly I think it's in the open
Countryside still
uh so the distance in comparing it to
other
hamlets and locations regarding
sustainability I think is flawed we've
nobody's mentioned the off-site
conjugation section 106 has not been
agreed so that's five and I've I've
talked about sustainability so I was
with four reasons why I can't support
this maybe if it comes back or had to
come in in this application not as such
it would have had more support but I
think it's premature there are more
questions and there are answers so I
can't support it I'm afraid
foreign
I believe everyone has now spoken apart
from myself would you like to speak
counselor no okay
um good uh
I mean look I'm when I said before does
anyone else want to speak before I put
my or in
um you've always everyone had spoken
since and I said more or less what I
wanted to say when you look through the
reasons for a refusal they're quite
clear
reason number one insufficient evidence
to demonstrate that the business is no
longer viable
we need that evidence if we haven't got
it this failed cs22 where we've been
removing what is otherwise deemed to be
a viable business that's going against
our policy
um fails to demonstrate that site can be
suitably drained we can see from the
other fa comments there is still a
statutory uh objection
Street Scene and um collection vehicles
and waste we still have the statutory
objection there are three reasons
straight away that we need to find to
overcome and I don't think I quite like
it is suitable to overcome it
um so I will absolutely be voting with
the officer's recommendation
I think it's a great shame because I do
think the scheme is
appealing
I'm not sure I'm overly excited by plots
two and three if I'm honest but some of
the others I think are quite appealing
and the the benefits of it in terms of
climate change and
um sustainability and that sort of stuff
it ticks all the right boxes but there
are so many things here that haven't
been satisfied that I cannot in all good
conscience Consciousness I can't even
speak tonight I'm struggling with my
speech
um
I can't vote uh to put this through with
those uh statue objections and with a
very clear steer that we do not have
sufficient evidence to make that uh that
judgment so
now that everyone has spoken we will
move to our boats we have got a proposal
to Grant but we don't have reasons for
going against the office of
recommendation are you willing to come
up with reasons or are you uh and this
is entirely up to you I'm not trying to
push you one way or the other but given
the direction of travel do you want to
maintain your proposal you can withdraw
it if you wish uh don't worry to write
that message okay yeah can I have your
reasons my reasons are I mean I think we
all said it's a very good scheme and I
do think we need some common sense here
um as Council Fleming said and I had
what it supports a climate change
emergency well what we all looking for
this um
in this area and the business now is not
sustainable I mean it's it it has gone
through the the floors via as I
understand
um
just a I know it's not a planning reason
Mr chairman but uh to eliminate the
stench I can tell it's pretty poor would
improve the environment
um for everybody um
locally thank you Mr chairman if they're
good enough reasons
because if you've got anything you want
to add to it please yes I'm
having listened to the various comments
around
um regrettably I'm going to withdraw my
seconding
I would I would like to see this
application come back
having had these those key issues that
you addressed that have been discussed
around the table looked at more
carefully because I do that I do think a
lot of us feel this is a good
application but it may be a little bit
premature premature so I will withdraw
regrettably my second thing of council
meals proposal yeah I just I just
remember just be careful whatever we're
talking about any future applications I
don't want anyone predetermining
themselves clearly there is some
lukewarm I think is the support is what
I'm going to use
um but we have to consider what gets put
in front of us so if this does come back
clearly we have to consider what's put
in front of us and we may well come to
the same conclusion we may not so please
don't pre-determine yourselves
um Council Mills I'm afraid that your
proposal is no longer viable or it's
going to stand um
the proposal to Grant uh sorry to Grant
to the fuse in line with the officer
recommendation so could I please have a
show of hands for those in favor of
uh they did I believe
someone did
I I I thought councilor Harvey did I
thought I asked him specifically to
Second it
um
but yet they have now if not I will
um we have it seconded
um supposedly recommendation could have
a show of Transportation favor refusal
please
yep uh against
one two two three three and abstentions
zero uh so therefore um committee
resolves to refuse application 2102 589
ful hogwood Farm um in Ox Hill okay
let's move on to our final application
of the evening which is application
reference
2201440 ful lower welcome Farm in
sneterfield our presenting opposite is
Sarah flanty
and so as soon as you are sat ready
comfortable and all good to go
um do feel free to start
thank you chairman
this is a full planning application for
the conversion of a barn to a dwelling
the application site is located two
kilometers Southwest of Smithfield in an
open Countryside location indicated by
the black dot on in the center of this
plan
the barn forms part of a wider complex
which makes up lower welcome Farm which
comprises modern and historic farm
buildings and a farmhouse the site is
located in the Greenbelt and Arden
special landscape area and is accessed
by an existing track of the a46 which
can be seen Crossing diagonally across
this image
here we see the proposed site plan the
barn subject of this application is
labeled Barn a and as seen in the center
of the slide
and the demolition of a modern
agricultural birding is proposed to
facilitate its conversion this building
is seen in this era
and to create a rear Garden scene here
the barn scene here at the bottom of the
slide bar B uh was gone to the planning
permission earlier this year for
conversion to a dwelling
here we see comparisons of the existing
elevation of The Barn at the top of the
slide
and the proposed elevations at the
bottom
a number of roof lights are proposed
along with the removal of the
traditional barn doors and replacement
with glazing so this would be the front
elevation of the barn and this slide
shows the proposed rear elevation
this page was taken phasing towards the
west and shows what is proposed to be
the front elevation of the of the
dwelling
the buildings understood from OS maps to
date the late 19th century
this photo is taken facing the Northeast
and shows some of the details of the
barn
the parking for the proposed dwelling
will be located to the left of this
photo on the air it's currently grasped
this final image is taken facing the
southwest and shows the modern
agricultural building to be demolished
in the foreground
to the rear you can see the application
Barn it's on the left of the image but
to the rear of the modern building
chairman there is some conflict with the
prince of development officers do not
consider that the proposal meets the
detailed wording of either policy as10
or the core strategy or policy be 10 of
the NDP in that the barn is neither
redundant or in disuse
in addition the proposed external
alterations to the barn are not
considered to be sensitive and as such
do not retain the its historic and
agricultural character contrary to
policy cs9 of the core strategy policies
be3 and be 10 are the NDP and part G of
the development requirements SPD the
recommendation is therefore to refuse
the application for the reasons detailed
on page 76 of your agenda thank you
there's also One update a correction to
the report which is detailed in your
update sheet uh this corrects the first
assessment sentence sorry of the first
paragraph of the design landscape impact
and impact of the character of the SLA
section this refers to an attached cart
shed this is an error and refers to a
different building at the wider site the
centers should instead read the
applications to convert a brick build
Barn into a dwelling thank you so thank
you very much let's call our first
speakers Corin Elliott
from Smithfield Parish Council I should
say
councilman good evening and welcome and
thank you very much for your patience
while we've gone through our previous
items I think you know the drill you'll
have three minutes I'll give you 30
second one before your time is up you
can stay seated to questions that'd be
great as soon as you press that red
button I will start the timer
as you can see from the planning history
there have been several planning
applications on this site conversion of
two bars was previously granted in 1990
and then renewed in 1996. however these
permissions then lapsed one of these
same bars was then granted permission
under reference two two
00143 full as recently as the 21st March
22
both SDC and the parish councils ported
this application and it was granted
under delegated powers
this new application for the second Barn
proposes a similar conversion
the parish council considers the
provision set out in B10 of our NDB do
support this I.E conversion and reuse of
existing buildings
the parish council has made a site visit
and observed that the brick Barn only
housed redundant old equipment and is
not at all suitable for the storage of
hay or modern machinery
the applicant proposes to recite the
modern steel Barn which is adjacent to
This Barn to a nearby field for which he
already has planning permission granted
under
1903077 agnott on the 6th of December
19.
this will be sufficient for his storage
needs without a new construction of
another steel Barn
CBRE have commented that the proposed
conversion is reasonable however with
some reservation regarding the glazing
to replace the barn doors
in conclusion the barish the parish
council considers that there is a net
gain to the openness of the green belt
and supports this application under the
provisions of NDP beta
thank you
councilworth thank you very much indeed
members do we have any questions for our
party counselor
Council Crump first it's a very quick
one uh what's the status your NDP has it
been to referendum
thank you very much made
um cancer Curtis
locations
okay do we have any other questions
members
no in that case cancel out thank you
very much for your time contribution
this evening
okay we'll call our final speaker of the
evening who is Mr Mark Blackman our
agent for the application
good evening Mr Blackman thank you for
your patience while we work through all
of our agenda items you've got an idea
of what's going on three minutes 30
second warning when you're ready I'll
start the timer
good evening ladies and gentlemen my
clients have two brick Built Barns at
their property and as previously
mentioned these both receive full
planning permission to convert into
residential dwellings in both 1990 and
again in 1996.
the officer's recommendation to refuse
the application before you today is of
course based primarily on policies
within the Stratford core strategy which
state that the conversion of rural
buildings is potentially permissible if
they are deemed to be redundant
however it must be recognized that a
discrepancy exists between the core
strategy and what is permissible under
General permitted excuse me General
permitted development rights
as you are no doubt aware a great many
bonds across the district have been
granted permission it's for conversion
through the class Q route whereby
submissions are made by applicants which
are judged solely against a list of
specific criteria and not against the
core strategy
specifically under General committee
development order class Q There is no
requirement for for a rural building to
be deemed to be redundant in order for
it to be converted
of course this begs the question why
hasn't the applicant submitted this
application as a class Q permitted
development application
the issue with the class Q route is that
local stakeholders aren't necessarily
consulted and planning officers have
only a narrow opportunity to influence
the proposed works
instead my clients have chosen to make
full applications for both bonds rather
than take the class Q route
this enables meaningful cons
consultation with stakeholders and this
has worked well in the initial
application for the first Barn where the
applicant was asked to redesign the
glazing Arrangements which they Judy did
and the application was subsequently
permitted
this application for the second Barn has
been supported by the parish council who
great who said they were appreciative of
the full application status as they were
given the opportunity to provide
feedback
in short my clients have adopted a
consultative approach not sought to
bypass the full full planning process by
utilizing their permitted development
rights
it is my client's contention that the
permitted development class Q route
represents a very strong fallback
position which should be recognized as a
material planning consideration when
assessing the application before you
the most recent case law states very
clearly that an applicant does not need
to have already secured a permitted
development approval or to have even
discuss the possibility of such an
approval for it to be considered as a
legitimate fallback position
to summarize my client has a strong
fallback position which has not been
taken into consideration 30 seconds this
should have been they should have formed
part of the weighing up process which
should also have considered the removal
of the substantial steel frame Barn from
the green belt if this application is
refused my client will of course
resubmit as a class queue application
where the conversion of This Barn meets
the required criteria and I would
therefore respectfully ask that members
take the fullback position into account
when forming their decision this evening
thank you very much and I would welcome
any questions especially regarding
reason two for refusal which I believe
could have been easily overcome
thank you
thank you very much indeed members do we
have any questions for our agent
well I certainly do
um
case law that you mentioned what is it
from the decision
the decision says there is
a pen for example on the landowner
having said precisely how he would make
use of any commission development rights
available to you under the General
Physics Department
okay that's helpful
that's helpful thank you I'm going to
refer to the officers about that later
on
um I actually don't have any other
questions I thought I did but cancer
Jennings
on The Barn at the moment there are
there Windows on it or is it
because I've noticed in the picture it
looked like there was
um it's either a plastic corridocious so
there are a number of what look like
skylights I guess so there are three
very large toilets which don't really
can bring the rear end
foreign
ER corrugated roof sheet
um this is obviously is a more modern
form of roofing and replacing what would
have previously been and originally been
a plane firearm the three very large
rectangles that you see on the current
reset of our skylights so they're
looking really glass through things the
bottom elevation you see there are small
constipation uh regulatory problems but
instead of being set within a modern
corrugated
concrete fiber roof scale our proposal
is to manage the reversion back to Plate
playing tiles
so there was a picture I think of
sorry you can see the briefing on this
slide and then you can see the yeah
they're just there okay
thank you very much
okay members we've got any other
questions that we would like to ask our
agent
no in that case thank you very much your
time contribution and of course your
patience as well
um now
I'm going to seek legal advice in a
second
um but what before I start doing that
because I think uh my my sister is just
getting all the information up in front
of us so we can have a look do we have
any other points of clarification for
our officers
Council Harvey
question just posed was why if I
understood it correctly why
consideration wasn't given to the
fallback class queue position could you
tell us why that was the case
of course yes
um so
we we can't give a definitive answer as
to whether a class Q fall back and
consists because no class Q application
has been submitted and with the
application it's a different it's a
different decision taking process to a
full planning application is assessed
against different National legislation
the general permitted development order
and in line with case law the the
gambone case law and also the Mansell
case law which refers to fullbacks in
order for something to be considered
genuine fallback there has to be a
greater than theoretical possibility
and the fallback scheme has to be more
harmful but in this instance we haven't
considered its great and theoretical
because no class queues before us
and therefore I I don't know whether it
will be acceptable as a class because I
haven't made that assessment against
that legislation if that makes sense
okay is anyone else got anything at
Council Rock
thank you chairman uh I mean nobody
wants to put officers on the spot here
but um
uh uh class queue applications are
always difficult I I I'm looking at uh
councilor Harvey here but we must have
some idea
I'm clearly the agent thinks it's
there's a good possibility that our
class Q application would be appropriate
is it unfair to ask if that's in a
reasonable assumption or not I bet are
you gonna say no I think you're you're
better phrasing it because we can't ask
officers to make a determination on
class Q right now and they don't have
full information in front of them what
we can do is say uh in principle would
would this fit the criteria to be
considered as a class queue thank you
chairman I I I accept your clarification
of my
no that was a very unhelpful change to
be quite honest
um the the answer to the Chairman's
question
is
yes it is possible that this uh Barn
could comply with class Q But as Sarah
has said uh we we haven't done that
assessment we haven't had the
information put in front of us so
neither you nor we can conclude that it
would
um if you push me on the pulling the
councilor Rock I would say that the
plans currently in front of you
would not meet the requirements for a
class queue but it is conceivable that
they could be made to that would be my
my current assessment
okay any other questions and points
clarification before I get my legal
advice
no I'm going to take two minutes while I
get my good advice please remain seated
if you would
okay we're back cancer Fleming
um
as you can imagine the uh the case
itself is Reams and reams of paper so
we've only managed to have what I say we
made so it's only managed to have a
quick skim through the selling points um
executive summaries and the final
summary as well so
um
I think the general
discussion just now was it is sensible
for us to defer so that a prop analysis
can be done of the case that was just
been presented to us
um I'm going to propose that we do that
on that basis and would seek a seconder
but of course thank you Council Redden
but of course you can come to your own
conclusions and if you feel it's
appropriate for us to make a decision
tonight based on the information that's
presented in front of you of course we
can go in that direction so I've made
that proposal cancer and could you just
confirm verbally that you want Oh happy
to Second happy just seconds yeah okay
um so we'll take a quick vote on that
this is to defer so that for
um uh research can be done into the case
law that was put forward show of hands
for those in favor of deferral
one two three that's unanimous
um so committee therefore resolves to uh
defer application
2201440 ful
f for the reasons given we have no
urgent business so it reminds me to
thank you all for your contributions
this evening our offices of course we're
getting everything going and our public
for taking part thank you very much and
we'll see in a couple of weeks